For a long time,
scientists,
clinicians,
and engineers
have been working
to find the next
generation medical
grade adhesive.
But, current methods
so far have been limited
because they're either
cytotoxic, they're rigid,
they don't adhere
well to dynamically
moving surfaces.
So, for the most part,
surgeons have been left
with sutures and
staple-based techniques.
And because of their
invasive character,
they create tissue
damage, and they are
prone to microbial infection,
it can be a
poor cosmetic outcome,
and they are time-
intensive, which increases
the overall cost.
The Bioinspired Approach
The gel is really interesting
because it combines some
recent advances in hydrogel
technology
with inspiration from nature.
And in this case, we turned
to the Dusky Arion slug.
When it gets threatened by
a predator, they change the
composition of their mucus,
and it becomes extremely
adherent to the underlying
substrate.
And then, they analyzed
the composition of this mucus,
and they found out it's an
ionically cross-linked
polysaccharide,
and covalently cross-linked
protein.
So it creates this unique
interpenetrating network.
We used many of the components
within this slug slime,
as inspiration to engineer
materials that behaved in
a similar way.
Components of the
Tough Gel Adhesive
There is an adhesive layer
and then there's a
tough gel component
that can dissipate the energy
and this gives the unique
mechanical properties.
By combining these two polymer
networks, we're able to achieve
much greater deformations.
The Tough Gel
The tough gel that we create
is about 90% water.
Most of it's water, and this
material through its
dual-network,
it's able to stretch up to
twenty-times its
initial length.
Which is quite interesting,
because the slug slime
that inspired it, can also
stretch to very high
magnitudes of deformation.
And that same slug slime
is about 95% water.
The Adhesive Layer
There are three major
interactions that are giving
these unique
adhesion properties.
These are covalent interactions:
We add in some coupling
reagents, and do some other
surface chemistry modifications
to be able to create these
strong covalent bonds
that create adhesion.
And ionic interactions:
When we think about these
materials carrying this
net positive charge,
And that tissues have a
net negative charge,
we can think about
these electrostatic
interactions.
Similar to laundry clinging
to each other in a dryer
after it's been operating.
And also, physical
interpenetration:
the physical network formation
between the tissue and adhesive.
Which is similar to reaching
and pulling out a telephone cord
from a bunch of tangled cords.
This bridging polymer
interpenetrates into the tissue,
and gel networks and really
forms a lot of entanglements.
The uniqueness about this
technology is it can actually
work in a wet and dynamic
environment.
You can adhere to surfaces
even in the presence of blood.
We've even tested this in the
case of a beating heart,
you can apply blood to the
tissue surface, you can apply
the tough adhesive & it adheres
very strongly to the surface.
Manufacturing Process
So, the first step is to
make the tough gel.
We make the tough gel by
essentially dissolving
alginate in solution, we
purify that aliginate solution.
And then, we add in some
polyacrylamide
into some syringes, we do
syringe mixing steps,
and then we inject the solutions
into some molds,
we can mold them into any shape
that we might be interested in.
We can apply our adhesive
components to it,
and we can couple those
adhesive polymers
to the surface of the gel,
which we can then
apply the composite gel
adhesive surface
to our wet tissue.
We apply compression
on the order of one or two
minutes,
and as that happens, the
adhesion energy increases
rapidly,
by that time, you're
already much higher
than most commercially
available medical-grade
adhesives
We found that our tough
adhesive adheres strongly to
skin, cartilage, and
arteries,
and we also found
that it can actually
close holes in the
heart tissue,
and it stops
bleeding from a
lesioned liver
tissue.
I think that if we
think about
developing a vision
for the future of
medicine,
I think we can think
about creating
adhesive sutureless
interfaces
developing materials
that can improve
the way that tissues
heal without
interfering with them
further
is what gets me excited
about this work,
as we continue to develop
this technology.